Michael learning let's know how much
maple syrup did the cast drink during
the filming process there's nothing easy
about chugging maple syrup I drank two
and a half bottles and Eric here drank
three and a half bottles because I felt
he need to drink more bottles Louie
oh go girlfriend I'm Your Mother come on
thorny you're losing to the rookie it's
embarrassing
come on rabbit stuff came out of me that
I don't remember putting in I like a
tire they wanted to do ice tea
that would have been a much easier thing
but after a couple takes of that they
realized them that the glug was too fast
didn't match syrup so they were forced
to do this there's a lower glug of
quotient the lgq which is a science that
you're right yet Kevin Odell asks do you
think Tom Selleck respects your
mustaches god that's a great question
Kevin those mustaches at least mine was
an ode to Burt Reynolds and also Billy
Dee Williams as Lando Calrissian
although your mustache and Super
Troopers two looks more like Cheech
Marin circa 78 I think James K Urich s
how many retakes did you guys do when
you start at the meowing in the new
movie you guys definitely break up with
Gaffigan when you revisit that scene in
the new meow hey buck has got him didn't
know boy when you have again showed up
for our first movie he was a stand-up
comedian he'd done a few commercials and
he knew all his lines all right now yeah
my scene now I don't think Boyd man do
you know how fast you were going but now
on Super Troopers - he showed up in his
private jet and he hadn't bothered to
study in fact it's just his Butler and
most of those scenes we shot over
shoulder